we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here's a very interesting voicemail our
friend juan wrote in
and uh talked about his doctor
and he says his doctor has some very
particular beliefs but is a very good
doctor and what do i think about this
take a listen to this
hey david it's juan here so
the only doctor that in my opinion is
worth a dime
or
has helped me enough
to where
i feel better on a day-to-day basis
is basically
a doctor
who believes
that trump
will be
reinstated
okay
um
this doctor
is a doctor that i have a lot of respect
for a doctor that i'm willing to pay
even though i can afford without
insurance
a doctor that if i come across
some lottery
i would even give him some of my lottery
uh
i find myself in a situation where
i have to go along with some of his
nonsense
because i fear that if i say something
that he doesn't like that i'll lose the
only doctor that has actually helped me
okay
can you believe that we've gotten to the
point
that we can't even
disagree without becoming disagreeable
or even losing a friendship
listen as i've said before
when people disagree about what the top
tax rate should be
it's not really the type of disagreement
that has a huge
material
impact on most relationships right if i
think hey we should have
uh the the top marginal tax rate should
go all the way up to 55 percent and you
believe we should have a flat tax of 18
percent there's like all right we just
disagree
it's not viscerally loaded in the same
way that some of these other things are
on the complete other end of the
spectrum would be beliefs like well
the jews should be killed right if you
find me a great doctor but the doctor
believes the jews should be killed it's
gonna be hard for me to put that aside
and say listen i'm just coming in here
for you know this is my ophthalmologist
and uh not to pick on rand paul um and
that's it and then there's a whole bunch
of in-between stuff for me
a doctor who is so delusional
that they believe trump is about to be
reinstated it's hard to imagine that
they are completely with it in every
other way
now there is this i've talked about this
condition before called paraphrenia
and paraphrenia is a mental disorder
where there's a very organized and
limited system of paranoid delusions
there's no hallucination
the intellect doesn't deteriorate the
personality doesn't deteriorate so
sometimes when when you're talking about
someone with paranoid delusions and or
schizophrenia
you talk to them and they seem like they
are not there in every sense like you
just say hey
you know what do you want for dinner
tonight and it's some unintelligible
rant and there's personality disorder
and there's a breakdown of their ability
to socialize in all these different
things
paraphrenia is different in which
sometimes someone has a very it's almost
like a walled off delusional belief it
might be in this case trump's about to
be reinstated listen i i understand that
except the signs of climate change i
know how germ theory works
gravity i've got no problem with what is
a good and bad diet how to best raise a
kid we agree on everything but i have
this walled off delusion about trump is
secretly the president or he is about to
be reinstated or whatever
that's a condition called periphernian
that exists
it's just usually not something like
the president who lost is about to be
reinstated it's not that so as far as
advice to juan
you got to do whatever you got to do
but to me
it seems weird
that the only delusional belief would be
trump is imminently going to be
reinstated let me know what you think on
the bonus show today we are going to be
recapping the primary elections from
earlier this week we are going to talk
about a man who has tested positive for
monkey pox
coved
and hiv at the same time
it's an incredible situation and we will
also talk about dr anthony fauci step
stepping down in december
after decades of public service and
republicans claiming he's doing it to
avoid prosecution prosecution for what
you might ask well i don't have the
answer but we'll try to figure it out on
the bonus show sign up at joinpakman.com
to get instant access